>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington D.C.
>> The "arraignment,
trial, and condemnation
of Captain William Kidd" is
from our trials collection,
which is part of the Law
Library's rare book collection.
We have digitized a subset
of the trials collection
that concern trials involving
piracy and that collection,
including this trial,
is available on law.gov.
Captain Kidd was found guilty
of murder and multiple counts
of piracy in trials held in
London, England, in 1701.
This particular report
indicates that it is by J. Nutt.
John Nutt was a printer
and bookseller who operated
out of the Savoy in London,
which was a structure
situated along the Strand
until it was razed in
the early 19th Century.
Little is known about John
other than that he passed away
in 1716, but his wife
successfully carried
on with the family's printing
business after his death.
While the trial appears
cut and dried,
the story behind
it is anything but.
Captain Kidd has often
been referred to as
"The Unlucky Pirate," but
based on research done
since his death, he may not
have been a pirate at all.
Kidd was born in Scotland,
but moved to New York
in the latter 1600s,
and was quickly accepted
by the society there, especially
so after marrying a rich widow.
He even was friends with
the Earl of Bellomont,
who would later become
the colonial governor
of New York and Massachusetts.
Rather than depend on
his wife's fortune,
Kidd became a privateer
on behalf of England.
Privateers are private citizens
who are granted "Letters
of Marque and Reprisal," or
passes by a country's government
that allows them to attack
and capture any enemy
ships during wartime.
As England was fighting
France at that time,
Kidd was given a letter
of marque allowing him
to capture any French or
pirate vessel he found.
Kidd was largely an unsuccessful
privateer, and by 1698,
he was having difficulty with
both his crew (which wanted
to attack any ship,
no matter its origin)
and his ship (which was
practically falling apart).
In fact, Kidd's murder charge
stems from a fight he had
with William Moore,
a gunner on his ship,
regarding Kidd not ransacking
a becalmed Dutch ship (as Dutch
ships were not covered
by his Letter of Marque).
These events were popularized
by a folk song published
in the early 1700s called
"The Ballad of Captain Kidd,"
which stated that Kidd,
quote "murdered William Moore
and laid him in his gore," end
quote, but the actual events,
as detailed in the trials,
appear to be much less bloody.
Kidd argued (and his witnesses
supported his statements)
that Moore was actively
fomenting a mutiny,
and was threateningly
sharpening a chisel when he
and Kidd began to fight.
During the battle, Kidd hit
Moore in the head with a bucket,
which ultimately led to
Moore's death a day later.
Finally, in 1698, Kidd and his
crew captured a large ship named
the Quedagh (or Cara) Merchant,
which was flying a French flag
and transporting goods under
passes from the French,
French East India Company.
The captain of the ship,
however, was English,
and argued with Kidd to
return the ship and its goods.
Kidd and his crew believed that
any ship working with passes
from the French East India
Company was, by association,
French, and so they did not.
All the iterations of the
East India Company were quite
politically powerful,
so it is no surprise
that when word got
back to England,
Kidd was branded a pirate,
and a warrant was
issued for his arrest.
He sent word to his friend and
investor, the Earl of Bellomont,
that he was falsely accused.
Bellomont convinced Kidd
come to Boston with his proof
that he had a letter of marque
and that the Quedagh Merchant
was a French East India ship.
Unfortunately for Kidd,
Bellomont had made a deal
with England to return Kidd, so
Kidd was imprisoned in Boston
for two years, and then was sent
back to England to stand trial.
In the meantime, the proof Kidd
sent, had sent ahead was "lost."
In the trial documents we
have, you can see Kidd pleading
for assistance of counsel
and for the evidence he
had previously provided,
unfortunately to no avail.
As such, he goes on
to defend himself.
In the murder trial,
he argues that he acted
in self-defense when
he struck Moore.
With regard to the charges
of piracy, Kidd again pleads
with the court to
provide the French passes,
and when they cannot be found,
he attempts to cross-examine the
witnesses regarding the passes,
and have evidence
submitted in that way.
His attempts at defense are
not successful, however,
and he was ultimately
found guilty of murder
and piracy, and executed
in 1701.
Interestingly enough, in
1910, a scholar claimed
to have found Kidd's
"lost" proof
in the British Public Records
archives, casting doubt
on his long-standing
characterization as a pirate.
>> This has been a
presentation of the Library
of Congress, visit
us at LOC.gov.